[Music]
for most of the year
the gulf of mexico is teeming with
marine life
from tiny crustaceans to massive baleen
whales
but every summer disaster strikes
around may animals begin to flee the
area
and soon creatures that can't swim or
can't swim fast enough begin to
suffocate
and die off in massive numbers from late
spring
to early autumn thousands of square
kilometers along the coast
become a marine dead zone unable to
support
most forms of aquatic life
this strange annual curse isn't unique
dead zones like this one have formed all
over the world
but to explore what's creating these
lethal conditions
we first need to understand how a
healthy
marine ecosystem functions
in any body of water that receives
sufficient sunlight
plant-like organisms such as algae
and cyanobacteria thrive
clouds of algae streak the surface of
deep waters
and in shallower regions large seaweeds
and sea grass cover the ground not only
do these organisms form the foundation
of local food chains their
photosynthesis
provides the oxygen necessary for
aquatic animals
to survive besides sunlight and
co2 algae growth also depends on
nutrients
like phosphorus and nitrogen while such
resources are typically in short supply
sometimes a surrounding watershed can
flood coastal waters
with these nutrients for example
a large rainstorm might wash
nutrient-rich sediment
from a forest into a lake these
additional resources
lead to a massive increase in algae
growth
known as eutrophication
but rather than providing more food and
oxygen this surge of growth
has deadly consequences as more algae
grows on the surface
it blocks sunlight to the plants below
these light deprived plants die off and
decompose
in a process which uses up the water's
already depleted
oxygen supply over time
this can reduce the oxygen content to
less than
two milligrams of oxygen per liter
creating an uninhabitable dead zone
there are rare bodies of water that rely
on natural eutrophication regions like
the bay of bengal
are full of bottom dwelling marine life
that has adapted
to low oxygen conditions that human
activity
has made eutrophication a regular and
widespread
occurrence nutrient rich waste
from our sewage systems and industrial
processes
often end up in lakes estuaries and
coastal waters
and the gulf of mexico is one of the
largest dumping zones on earth
for one particular pollutant fertilizer
american agriculture relies heavily on
nitrogen
and phosphate-based fertilizers 31
states including america's top
agricultural producers
are connected to the mississippi river
basin and
all of their runoff drains into the gulf
of mexico
farmers apply most of this fertilizer
during the spring planting season
so the nutrient flood occurs shortly
after
in the gulf decomposing algae
sinks into the band of cold salt water
near the sea floor since these dense
lower waters
don't mix with the warmer fresh water
above it can take
four months for tropical storms to fully
circulate
oxygenated water back into the gulf
this dead zone currently costs u.s
seafood and tourism industries
as much as 82 million dollars a year
and that cost will only increase as the
dead zone gets bigger
on average the gulf dead zone is roughly
15 000 square kilometers
but in 2019 it grew to over 22
000 square kilometers approximately the
size
of new jersey human activity
is similarly responsible for growing
dead zones
around the world so what can be done
in the short term countries can set
tighter regulations
on industrial runoff and ban the dumping
of untreated sewage into ocean waters
on farms we can plant buffer zones
composed of trees and shrubs to absorb
runoff however long-term solutions
will require radical changes to the way
we grow food
farmers are currently incentivized to
use
techniques that reduce the health of the
soil and rely heavily
on nitrogen-rich fertilizers but there
will be less need for these chemicals
if we restore the soils natural
nutrients
by planting diverse crops that manage
soil erosion
and fertility hopefully we can make
these fundamental changes
soon because if we don't the future of
our marine
ecosystems may be dead in the water
fish need our help by 2050
there will be more plastic and trash in
the ocean
than fish could the earth really run out
of
fish find out more about the serious
threat of
overfishing and what we can do to
prevent it with this video